534 all right let's talk about las vegas
which is where we live and neon which is
like everywhere the two are linked
forever those big signs are a part of
what makes our city so unique and today
the company behind a lot of those signs
in a lot of the history is being
celebrated yeah you know a lot of ways
john yesko has helped shape the image of
las vegas spectacular neon signs we're
talking about the welcome to las vegas
sign from decades ago to the more recent
towering gateway arches outside of the
strat well our hector mejia is live
there as the folks from yes go show off
some of their great stuff what do you
got hector
yeah good morning guys and so this is
one neat thing i was reminded of this
morning when a lot of the casinos get
demolished and replaced by new ones
these signs are so special we even have
a museum to store these signs and
joining us live we have jeff young
senior vice president of yes go so
family company here we are a hundred two
years later what do you think your
grandfather would say after thinking of
the success and seeing everything
involved good morning oh good morning
and he'd be blown away with what's
happened with las vegas he spent
virtually his entire career building
what has become las vegas in terms of
the signs and lights and we have been
really humble and proud partners of an
unbelievable economy here so what would
you think yeah you got you you gotta
wonder i mean 1932 1928 you realize how
small las vegas was and that's when he
was really getting his start here with
signs
and show us you know we want to
highlight at least one sign here tell us
why one of these is so special among so
many other special ones yeah it's hard
to pick a favorite sign but this mint is
something special and this uh this color
photo was recently uh uncovered uh the
mint is gone but in its in its day when
it was put in uh pink neon everywhere
they originally were thinking about
calling it the hippodrome if you can
imagine that they decided on the mint
instead and it uh it certainly
typified
um the glamour and glitz and sparkle
that las vegas has had from the creative
sign perspective how would you say las
vegas
has changed
oh the size and scale has just been
you know magnified significantly i mean
you look at you look at the palms you
look at the harm and wall you look at
all these these gigantics the aria all
these giant signs yeah the scale is just
unbelievable and the digital side of
things is really taken
taken uh taken over and also as the
footprint the population of las vegas
gets bigger seems like so do the science
very much yeah it's been really fun not
only to build them but we we maintain
them so we're on these signs all the
time making sure that they're lit up
for all the visitors and guests that
come here awesome well thank you for
joining us we still have a few more
topics to talk about still ahead we'll
talk about the perhaps the most
complicated sign out there and just how
complex these signs have gotten over
these last 102 years that's still ahead
of the next hour for now reporting live
hector mejia live local now